we're here to introduce Jason sundram
from facebook he's going to give a talk
on full stack approach to data
visualization terabytes and beyond and
jason is a quantitive engineer at
facebook where he creates visualizations
applications to yield insights from
petabytes of data before that he was a
senior data scientist at PayPal where he
analyzed and visuals visualized geodata
he's an avid violinist at a chamber
musician and a co-founder of the Hayden
enthusiasts a barrier collective that's
performing the complete string quintet
quintet of Joseph Haydn so let's welcome
Jason and we have lots of good things to
look forward to thanks thank you hey
everyone I'm Jason I'm here to talk to
you today about some things I learned
while developing data visualizations at
Facebook actually want to start by
telling you a story so like every good
story this one begins with something
you're probably all familiar with
refriger spam so in the spring of 2012 I
was living in somerville massachusetts
see miles from Boston I got an email
from a recruiter at Facebook and I
actually replied to the email because I
was intrigued by the possibilities for
visualization that Facebook's rich and
textured data offers and the fact that
the weather is like maybe a little bit
nicer in the Bay Area I'm not going to
lie that probably played some part in my
decision so like after some
soul-searching I drove across the
country and I was like yeah San
Francisco I'm here and of course you
have to take this picture in front of
the Golden Gate Bridge so I did got to
follow the rules so like Here I am I'm
in San Francisco and I found my way
myself like on the way to facebook on
one of these shuttle buses that everyone
talks about now before everyone was
talking about them so that was cool for
a while and I was headed to mpk as we
call the campus here and I was actually
like filled with a fair amount of
uncertainty and doubt about like what is
it that I'm doing it facebook why am I
here
so why the doubt well this is pi beta
right we're here to talk about Python
and data and I came to Facebook and I
was talking about PHP and high then I
was like oh [ __ ] HP and like hi I don't
really know sequel that well which I
guess I shouldn't event but you heard it
here I wasn't very cool I'm still not
great as equal so Facebook's core
technologies were written in PHP which I
really didn't know very well and all of
my familiar tools the things that I knew
really well Python like all the you know
data manipulation tools that probably a
lot of you are familiar with I also kind
of wasn't sure how to use them so I was
like what am I doing here all the things
I'm good at can't do so fortunately
there's a happy ending right and not
just gonna like walk off the stage and
go so I'm going to tell you about how I
answered some of those questions and I'm
came up with the following revelations
so first all big data has to become
small data in order to be visualized
even a retina display only has about
five million pixels so if your data is
bigger than five million points you got
to start thinking about how to make it
smaller second what I'm calling the
fresh data revolution you've heard it
here first it's really about why real
time systems are really great for big
data and finally if life hands you more
data consider using more pixels so I
want this talk to leave you feeling
inspired and empowered to use these
revelations in your own work I'll talk
about the stack along the way so they're
going to be these little nuggets of
charts that are going to be deep packed
with meaning what's up so just want to
do a quick surveys kind of get a sense
of like what are what we have in common
here so we're all Python programmers
I think that's everyone's hands good
might be in the wrong room so do how
many people do front end work like in
JavaScript or anything like that okay
ten percent maybe um backends systems
okay a lot of that database stuff data
bases good no databases CSV files
excellence who did I miss like it who
didn't who hasn't raised their hand yet
okay people will have hands so let me
talk about my team a little bit we have
diverse skills right we build dated
driven applications for insights so we
have were small but we're mighty we have
an economist a machine-learning PhD a
data engineer and a visualization person
which is me and we have somebody to help
us figure out what are the good things
to do and what we really should not do
I'll let you guess which one of those
people is with that face we also part
I'm from designers when we can get it
because we are not designers although we
would very much like to be good at
design so we're very much on the
exploration side of the kind of
explanation exploration continuum that
data visualization sort of falls into
you so on the explanation side you might
sort of have like a data science blog
post where you like drill really deep
into some particular issue and you you
think about it and you kind of tease out
all of the possible possible subtleties
and then you go hey this is what I see
this is what I understand exploration
sort of is a lot more open-ended so it's
really about building tools to help
other people say I have a question how
can I answer this and we use Python
wherever possible so it's not real it
might be religious but I'll say it's not
religious we like we like to use Python
wherever possible for our work so people
talk a lot about big data and then write
books about it too
and I guess there's some guy who's just
has a head shot he's big data I guess I
don't know that guy but I want to meet
him so people talk about small data to
and then I read this post in the
Atlantic about thick data and they mean
all kinds of different things and you
know just like adjectives like noun like
add data on and then you've got
something apparently but as one of my
friends on Twitter and as birch said
earlier big data is really kind of the
same thing as small RAM and I think
there's some truth to that so like super
put more ram in your machines but at
some point like try shipping a Giga gig
of data to your browser and you've got
problems try displaying as i said
earlier more than 5 million points on
the screen and again more problems but
when i was the most excited about when i
joined facebook was figuring out what it
means what does it mean to try and
visualize big data so they're all these
companies we're providing like solutions
for big data problems and at Facebook
there are lots of different systems for
charting and exploring data and when I
first started there were like a lot of
questions that I have because that's
what you come to facebook with when
they're you're like so much data very
curious so just you know thinking about
any question you might have and there's
data to think about how to answer that
question and so I was like how many
photos are uploaded permanent and how
does that vary over the course today and
how does it vary by country and by
mobile device and just any other
dimension that you can imagine it like
let's let's slice and then maybe do some
dicing because that's what we do so
there's like 350 million photos uploaded
per day to facebook which is I think if
the math is right like one flickr every
week so like when I went to do these
queries this is what I got and I looked
at it
yeah and I kept looking at it and
seriously I was like the curiosity and
the light was just drained for my eyes
and I was like let's browse the internet
this was not going to last so I had this
frustration and so of course like you do
when you're frustrated you ask your
friends like what to do and so I think
cross filter j/s which is this amazing
in browser technology for slicing and
dicing data I was like I will use this
this is good and so I was like hey cross
filter + hive and you know oh I got
crickets and then I got wisecracking
crickets which to be fair probably the
best kind of crickets so I was like okay
maybe sampling sampling could be a thing
let's try that but so if you take 350
million things and you turn them into
three and fifty thousand things all of a
sudden things get a lot more tractable
but then you introduce all kinds of
errors because of sampling is hard to do
correctly especially on data that's
nuanced so you introduce errors and then
you also don't understand what errors
even introduced and I really cared about
showing the right numbers one of those
showing numbers I think that's important
and then it came to me aggregation
aggregation is the key to visualizing
beat big data and it turns out actually
to my shame that people in mb I have
been talking about things like Oh app
and cubes since like the 1970s before I
was born awesome but given like the
profound unsexy ness of like the letters
bi and like my personal distaste for
like acronyms at all I was just like
yeah whatever these things can't
possibly be important so like all those
who forget or ignore history I was
doomed to repeat it so I did so here you
can see dated up csv which is um as you
can pretty much tell not real data
because it fits in a gist on github it's
the lower file snip snip it right over
there which could have in theory
billions of rows obviously doesn't and
the insight that I rediscovered from the
1970s unearthed it for myself was that
despite the billions of Records there's
actually a limited number of values that
can be present in each
so it's the cardinality of the columns
that really matter 100 rows of data
could be condensed into for example 100
32 year old males from california on
tuesday at I am right all of a sudden
you've got a hundred fold compression
factor just like that by describing the
possibilities rather than actually
having literal data representation so
it's the product of these cardinalities
how many different ages how many
different genders how mentis oom they're
just two genders by the way how many
states how many countries and how many
times this really determines the maximum
number of rows required to characterize
your data set so you can see above how
that aggregation for this case could be
expressed in sequel so props to me I
actually wrote a little too sequel I'm
like very proud of myself and you can
imagine like doing some kind of
bucketing on the ages on the countries
or the states to kind of keep
cardinalities in each of those different
columns under control so like now we
kind of have an approach that will
return a reasonable number of rows but
how do you actually do this query right
like you're still talking to hive and
that means the big pinwheel of death and
then internet forever so that's a little
problem you have to solve and the answer
is basically cheat right so have an
in-memory database so big data is small
Ram get big Ram so in-memory databases
give you big Ram to go with your big
data scuba is an in-memory database
developed at Facebook there's a paper
about it from which I stole this pretty
awesome figure kind of you know just
explaining what's going on or trying to
explain what's going on but basically it
distributes queries over lots of
different machines all of which have
that have data is stored in RAM so
queries that would take like tens of
minutes in hive or even presto which is
a lot faster than hive only takes
seconds in scuba unfortunately Scoob is
not currently in open source project so
depending on your data volume you might
be ok using sequel a and memory on a
single server that has a lot of RAM
you want to try this on your own work or
you might have to do a little research
into memory databases okay so we've got
a way of querying a database and now we
have a database and then we need
something to like give us data like in
the front end so this is the API layer I
used tornado because i love python and
also python like allows me to get my
fingers into all of facebook's
infrastructure by a thrift which is
basically a serialization format for
talking to java PHP whatever other the
backend services in c++ that we have
including scuba gzip csv the last two
parts there are choices I made pretty
carefully there's a bunch of other
serialization formats for sending data
from browsers or sorry getting data in
browsers from from servers so like
everyone's first choice I think like you
just like yeah you use JSON JSON is like
really good at describing data like
JavaScript speaks it natively and it's
like awesome but it's really verbose so
when you're trying to send a lot of rows
usually spend a lot of time just
transferring the data so CSV is a lot
more compact than JSON and gzip would
you can actually just set the right
header from your tornado server and your
browser will go hey that's gzip data I
know how to unpack that if its native
code in your browser you don't ship any
extra dependencies it's great it was the
right trade-off for me for compactness
and overall speed which overall speed by
the way is like encoding transfer
decoding so there's these things that
will make your data smaller but then you
have to like ship a decoder along and
then decode data on the client there's
actually a project from the New York
Times called tamper which was launched I
think last week it's another
serialization protocol which really
promises pretty good compression and I'd
like to look into it there's no Python
encoder currently so I have been
planning to write one if somebody else
wants to raise their hand and say like
they'll do it awesome looks around
hopefully no
okay i'm going to write one so finally
we're like at cross filter which is the
thing that sort of started this whole
question like how do i get data into the
browser and use cross filter to like
really do these fast intersections cross
filter is open source it was done by
Mike Bostock who's now at the New York
Times it allows you to do the fast
slicing and dicing on millions of rows
and it allows you to update these
coordinated views so you know you're
selecting a range of Ages and you see
the genders like this update you know in
milliseconds there's no extra query of
the server that's involved DCJS is a
really nice library that allows you to
just get charts for free in the browser
without like going through d3 and going
okay right how does d3 work again which
is what ends up happening unless you're
spending a lot of time in d3 so those
are pretty much all the pieces this is
the tiny snippet of code that allows you
to use the cross filter API with the
aggregates that we well that we computed
in sequel and this comes basically it's
just a small modification of stuff that
was already in the documentation but it
took me a while to figure out rtfm so
here's the whole picture of what what
we've talked about so far so we needed a
data source this is coming in from PTL
which is basically this another facebook
technology that has been talked about
there's a good paper on PTL and puma
which basically you can think of it as
just telling a log file you're getting
data from tons of servers and all these
different streams and they're just going
into this in-memory database cults Cuba
and it allows you to then query from
your from your API server this in-memory
data that's pretty fresh and of course
like we have our CSV gzip API but
there's also JSON API is that you can
make for smaller queries where you don't
really care that much about you're not
sending huge amounts of data you're
sending you know metadata for easy
JavaScript usability um although psl is
internal to facebook apache flume is an
open source project that will give you
some of the same capabilities and so
let's take a look at the full system so
I really wanted to do this but I
actually had some problems convincing
our legal department it was a good idea
so check out the cross Walter demo page
and pretend you're playing with fresh
facebook data it like I really in all
seriousness I suggest like go to the
cross filter page and play with the demo
it will inspire you it's fast look at
what I can show you if I can't show you
the actual tool I'll show you the impact
of the tool so this man is President
Barack Obama during the State of the
Union address this year an analyst at
Facebook was able to use this tool that
I made to slice and dice the audience
around different topics related to key
words in his speech as she was speaking
them so they would hear a word and they
go oh what's being said about this word
and the piece of information highlighted
at the bottom here men are talking about
the economy women are talking about
inequality that data came directly from
queries that an analyst at Facebook did
using the using the stack that was
described in the previous slide so the
API that the the person in the newsroom
used was this really old API called the
telephone so that's like this puzzle
piece that we haven't quite figured out
how to make this work so there's
actually a person at Facebook with the
telephone not me and a person in the
newsroom with a telephone saying hey
what's what can you tell me that's
interesting and the person that facebook
is like typing and talking so technology
meets the real world
okay so what's next so what I did here
actually was to develop a new stack for
working on agile data products at
Facebook one I was much more comfortable
with and I'd like to extend that stack
by building reusable cross filter
friendly charting components using
reacts to make assembling visualizations
like this a little easier in the future
react for those of you who may not be
familiar with it is basically a
JavaScript library for really making it
easy to make user interfaces basically
web front-ends out of components instead
of like just crazy soup of JavaScript
with any luck you should see some of
that work open source later this year if
you've actually done any worked with
react in d3 hit me up afterwards I'd
love to talk about it okay so we talked
about one way to take a big data set and
make it more manageable using
aggregation so here's another one fresh
data I forgot to save revolution fresh
data revolution what I mean by fresh
data of course is timely or real-time
data so Facebook has I think like our
latest published numbers is like 500
terabytes of data that we get per day
which is like sort of a lot and so like
if you if you divide that down that's
like roughly 5 gigabytes per second give
or take so that five gigabytes of data
is sort of a lot so like actually put
through a network card but if you only
care about certain kinds of data like
maybe English text posts or check-ins or
some other kind of specific data type
you can actually be down in a really
manageable range of data almost before
you know it fresh data is relevant
because it's recent and it's exciting so
I think you should really add this to
your big data buzzwords big data thick
data fresh data but I have a secret I
really was excited about this because I
wanted to make some blinking left on my
monitor I was like yeah data should make
like
colors happen I want a good screens they
were so don't tell anyone so at Facebook
every month or two the company has a
hackathon there are at least 24 hours
but they can last several days during
that time if you choose to participate
you can come up with an idea for a
project or partner with other people for
projects I'm at and at the end everyone
has a chance to present their work to
other hackers many features on facebook
com actually started attacking on
projects video upload chat and even the
like button we're all hackathon projects
as a data and visualization keek a
little less interested in shipping
features to facebook com and I'm more
interested in making projects to
visualize data it's the reason that I
actually drew in facebook in the first
place so my hackathon projects have
really been about around data
visualization and the first one that I
did was to try to build a real-time map
of public check-ins I gave a talk at
strada a couple years ago about
visualizing geo data and I made some non
real-time visualizations of check-ins
using towel mill and processing this
time I wanted to build something similar
for the web and make it real time so it
was this but I didn't know that at first
of course I never leak used leaflet da
je s before I'm going to talk about all
the different pieces and kind of how
they fit together but I'd heard really
good things about it leaflet is a
basically a library for displaying tiles
on tiled maps like Google Maps so you
don't have to load tons of data at once
you can just zoom in and get details on
demands i use this cloud Ned cloud cloud
made towel source and that was pretty
easy to get working but I needed
actually not just to ship a map I need
to show data on the map so remember p
cell from before i'm starting like right
at the bottom of this the web plant and
then I was like okay great how do I get
data so that I'm like starting right at
the top left PTL is my data source so I
can get the stream of public check-ins
awesome but then I was like okay how do
all those middle things work how do i
get from i'm sitting here
in my you know SSH terminal and I have a
stream of data coming through and then i
have this web server that's showing me a
map and there's nothing i needed to tie
those things together so i have this
python script called processor py which
basically tells me how to reformulate
that data and how to ignore data that i
don't want to touch ignoring data really
quickly is a bit of an art but it's
actually really important especially in
real time systems so processor not py
just says hey this is a public check-in
do stuff with it and formats like a nice
little packet for me zeromq i didn't
know anything about except for that
people had had talked about it and said
it was good so I was like hey more new
things and the documentation for 0 and Q
is like I think it's like the high water
mark for like documentation for projects
it's really super readable it was
actually almost fun so I read the docs
and decided on this push-pull
architecture where the processor script
can just like push data away once it's
done with it and the tornado web server
which of course is going to be serving
up our web page it's going to be pulling
data that's getting pushed by this other
process so I've got a pusher of like
data that's happening in real time and
I've got a puller the question is great
I've got all this data coming in how do
I get this to the client so what better
way to do this then web sockets which is
sort of just like continue the flow I'd
also never used web sockets but
everything had been going well so far
and I wasn't like sunrise yet so I was
like let's keep going with WebSockets
and it turns out web sockets are pretty
easy to use so they sound like they
might be they sounded to me like they
might be complicated but it was really a
few lines of JavaScript so the WebSocket
basically receives new events and puts
them in a queue in on the front end so
we're getting this queue of data points
coming in and I just have an update loop
that just repaints the screen every 30
seconds to get a good frame rate and
then I can just use d3.js
to show the points kind of arriving so
they're just getting a little bit
smaller as they seem to like fall on the
map I limited the size of the key to
make sure that there weren't like you
know crazy bursts in the data volume so
that you need to end up with like you
know a million points or something like
that so for performance reasons I
limited that to about 500 I'm sure that
number could be tweaked a little bit and
just throw away things if you get too
many very principled so I had this check
in tech events and I had these dots but
I was like I need colors for the dots
colors are important when you're trying
to make blinking lights so I realized
seconds often have text associated with
them and I thought hey wouldn't it be
cool if we could look at the sentiment
for the for the text and color the dots
by the sentiment and it turns out one of
my teammates Ryan Rosario sit in back
the room who will be talking about his
sentiment classifier later this
afternoon in this room have built a
sentiment classifier so it's like super
let's just wear this thing up and we'll
just get a score for each one of these
chickens between you know negative
positive neutral and all of a sudden I
went from you know flashing dots to
flashing colored dots and believe me
that was a good moment i'm going to show
you an early screenshot the first
screenshot i have in the project working
and there's like a map with dots on it
it's a lot more exciting when it's when
it's running I unfortunately didn't save
a movie at the time but this is the
finished product so like basically one
night of hacking and lots of blinking
lights so as a day to visualization hack
I didn't have any hopes of getting this
like incorporated into facebook com I
don't know who would want to go to their
newsfeed and see something like this if
you do I like you so I just set it as my
screensaver using web saver which is
this awesome thing for OS X which allows
you to take a URL and turn it into your
screensaver so if you have any kind of
fun data sketches you just you know put
them wherever you want host them and
just point this web server at the URL
and all of a sudden you've got a server
and I got all these sparkling dots which
is what I was hoping for right the
things you do for sparkling dots after
the product has been running for a while
I thought I didn't started to notice
some patterns kind of can't see this
very well at all it looks better on that
screen but it doesn't really help you
guys um so I made a static version of
the map yeah sorry I didn't mean to make
you do that so I just took a few hours
of data and plotted them on a hex pin
map and so these things are actually
little hexagons and that's actually a
map but okay let's just let's move on so
although this might have been were
informative about long-term trends I
looked in particular I suspected that
people in the UK we're just more
negative than everyone else gosh and you
can see like a little red dog little red
angry dot but it wasn't a blinking light
and so people looked at it as they said
that's cool but then they stop looking
at it because I wasn't blinking at them
so people in my group started showing
actually the live map to people at the
end of meetings they're just like hey
check it out some blinking lights and it
was like it started all of these
conversations about real-time data and
using text algorithms so even though it
was like basically let's show Jason some
shiny lights it actually started some
really good conversations and eventually
it led to getting like you know the most
important thing you could possibly do
when you're making an internal tool
executives saying nice things about the
tool and you know starting some good
conversations so to build on this
approach which is just to recap p tail
plus some NLP + 0 mq + tornado so it's
web sockets i'm like okay cool I've got
these five things I understand how they
work so let's let's do something else
with them so I decided real-time text
analytics was like a thing I should work
on and I saw this ad in my feed and on
Facebook and I was like yeah people are
talking about Game of Thrones on
facebook and if you don't watch Game of
Thrones as soon
possible you'll find out things you
would prefer not to know but what are
people saying about Game of Thrones
similarly for house of cards within like
a few days of being released house of
cards on netflix people like 7 million
people had talked about this thing on
facebook so like seven million is like a
little bit too much too i don't know how
fast you guys read there's too much to
read for me so let's take this real-time
data approach and see like as you're
watching a live event what are people
saying about this event I tried this
during the oscars I was actually I
projected this visualization while I was
trying to watch the Oscars and it turns
out yes it's super cool to see what
people are saying like during a real
time event that's also really
distracting so i can't say i recommend
this as like your day-to-day viewing
experience so here's the same sort of a
very similar architecture to what I had
before the major differences are we're p
tailing a different data source we have
these magic NLP boxes and the UI at the
end is kind of different so i'll show
you the UI this is a screen capture from
American Idol I ran it later for the
Discovery Channel show naked and afraid
if you're not familiar with the show two
contestants try to survive for 30 days
after being dropped in a strange place
with nothing but the clothes on their
back and the first thing they do when
they get there is they take their
clothes off and of course they're
strangers of opposite genders so I guess
that's how you get viewers these days so
as a result of making this tool I was
actually to get able to get on air
integrations of of insights that I'd
picked up from these audiences about for
the show American Idol for- afraid and
for insert more here it's very exciting
so one of the things that's had a lot of
engagement is just entertaining hashtags
that people end up creating and ensuring
and producers are like oh my gosh we
never would have found this hashtag
without without this tool so one of
those hashtags was for naked and afraid
anyone want to guess it was lots of
butts
so I'm very proud and I'm sure my
parents are too so what's next for this
approach I think using cubism j/s is
another front-end framework for time
series visualization it's designed for
actually doing principled display of
time series data and it uses horizon
plots this is a little washed out here
but you can see basically you don't have
to worry about giant bars like you're
like oh a spike in traffic it just
actually just folds over itself nicely
and gets denser so I think horizon plots
are pretty awesome there's not currently
a nice Python backend for supporting
cubism so I'm going to think about
working on something like that if you
use graphite or cube as your back-end
you're you're good to go so here's like
the silliest part of this talk so like
we've got big data why not use a big
screen right it's obvious should do this
like a really big screen so like around
the corner there's you meant you may
have seen if you haven't seen it yet
like go out not now right now like
literally right around the corner
there's a 20 foot long display so I'm
talk a little bit about the process of
kind of putting that together that's
part of what facebook calls the
executive briefing center this work was
done with as a collaboration between me
and some other folks at facebook and the
design studio pitch Interactive's a lot
of the front end stuff you'll see here
is done by with those guys in the bottom
right here you can see what looks like a
server rack but this is actually the
super exotic piece of hardware called a
Vista spider x 20 which is like
necessary for powering like 20 screens
at the same time I never heard of such a
thing before I started this project so
I'm really lucky that i worked at
facebook and other people know a lot
more than i do so here the specs which I
really drooled over for a while so it
just 20 feet long 41 megapixels 36 touch
points and 20 individual displays so why
would we do something like this so as
you can maybe tell this is a marketing
driven project
here's what marketing has to say about
the project I'm not going to read that
to you but for me it was about a way of
taking data and making it more tangible
and more real for me was about taking
data visualization and turning it into
data visualization to present clients
with data that really touches them and
really speaks to them and in turn they
can touch it and speak to it if they
want so how did we do this it took about
two to three months actually to put it
together there are hardware people who
knew about spiders and next 20s a
visualization studio very talents people
need to sort of help figure out how to
put out all the pieces together and all
of us to keep saying no to marketing
people like you know we can't do that
it's going to take you long this is not
a good idea so saying no cannot can be a
full-time job and it was for a while
actually so we knew we need a lot of
screens so we started you know building
these mounts and we started calling the
project the wall it's called the
insights wall now and Wes the guy
pitched interactive actually have this
great idea let's just show a chrome tab
in full screen mode which basically
means hey you can just use your normal
you I stack for doing like web stack for
making the UI awesome however we ended
up just finding out that to get decent
animations we had to use WebGL so we
have the whole sort of Facebook stack
that I've talked about earlier presto DB
like pretty much every piece of Facebook
infrastructure you can think of I wrote
the connector to or used an existing
connector to you to pull data for this
wall we use data swarm pipelines to
together huge amounts of data and sort
of summarize them every time we a new
client comes in we actually use presto
DB to do a query that takes a few
minutes to calculate information about
their particular audience and then we
built some visualizations that everyone
can see that's not very specific to
anyone that are just fun for people who
are visiting with 36 touch points come
like a lot of different problems I want
to show you this loop I don't have all
you hear but this is West from pitch
interactive just doing some really
principle testing where he's just
rolling his body over the wall I thought
that was really important to show and
like what you can't hear is he's just
stink bugs bugs bugs bugs bugs so 36
touch points means a lot of API calls
actually so being a sink is super
important it's really great that
Fernanda supports this out of the box
getting the IRS touch screen tuned was
also really important trending data
means you have to deal with profanity
showing up and visitors being shown
profanity I never expected that I was
enough to work on that one one
particular federal campaign actually had
a hashtag that was related I didn't know
at the time to like a test particular
cancer awareness but the hashtagged did
not make that clear so this is the
architecture you can see it's got a lot
in common with the previous things you
can see all the data sources tau as a
graph database we have pressed ODB scuba
the pitch interactive used nodejs for
all the visualizations so we got to add
a new box and you see here like this is
the impact this is a bunch of people
looking at their data and getting pretty
excited about it and of course like when
you're excited you take pictures so you
can see at least one one person is is
taking a picture of the thing he's
seeing if you want to check it out it's
right around the corner I'd love to give
you your own personal tour if you want
to want to know about it so what have we
learned in order to visualize data you
got to make it small and or if you can
you got to make your screen big and what
I learned was that to be successful in a
new place really requires combining the
familiar the things you know really well
with the new is you can find a way to
play to your existing strengths while
developing new ones you'll seldom go
wrong if any of this was at all
interesting to you please come find me
afterwards I'd love to talk more about
it and if there are questions I would be
happy to answer them
quick